jennifer coolidge
and wait hold on one thing
wait hold on wait hold on okay
yeah would we expect anything less from
jennifer coolidge as she celebrates
nabbing her first ever emmy award i just
want to say um you know i took a
lavender bath tonight
and um right before the show and it made
me swell up inside my dress
and uh
i'm having a hard time speaking um but
anyway um
i um
but voice or no voice jennifer is
determined to give her acceptance speech
hold on wait wait wait wait
even as the music tries to play her off
stage and thank you to my amazing uh
team wait hold on no this is a once in a
lifetime thing and i'm full i'm full
wait wait wait hold on wait
we'll need to do some fact checking but
this might just be the first time
someone's received two separate playoff
songs and my sister is here tonight and
wait hold on one thing wait hold on wait
hold on
okay jennifer's new trophy is for
outstanding supporting actress in a
limited series celebrating her standout
performance on the white lotus
i can't i can't do this
you know this is i just realized it's
too early for me it's okay
thank you gosh
i just um
what a night
i am i just want to say uh you know to
my fellow nominees um just to be in your
company it's incredible
yeah she's already booked a trip for
next season
listen i i'm in desperate need of a
massage is that possible and you know we
all want to know about season two
because jennifer's coming back
[Music]